Traductor: Liliana Hernández Toscano
Revisor: Penny Martínez
La definición de transformar, nos dicen,
es hacer cambiar de forma a algo o a
alguien y transmutar algo a otra cosa.
Entonces es importante esta definición,
porque se va a aplicar finalmente
al resto de la charla que vamos a tener
y que se va a tener también que aplicar
a la parte positiva y negativa
de la transformación.
Yo creo que no puedo encontrar algo más
representativo para la transformación
que esta hermosa mariposa,
que finalmente
de ser un capullo se convierte en algo
tan diferente y tan exquisito
y, finalmente uno dice
bueno pues sí ese es el poder
que tiene la naturaleza sobre todos
los seres vivos en este planeta, ¿no?
Como psicóloga y profesora que soy,
he sido capaz de patentar y de constatar
transformaciones
tanto en alumnos como en pacientes,
y efectivamente
para aquellas personas que creen
que los seres humanos no podemos cambiar
y que muchas veces escuchamos:
“No, las personas no cambian”,
pues les tengo noticias.
Sí, sí cambiamos,
a veces involuntariamente,
a veces sin darnos cuenta.
Y bueno para ello yo quiero
presentarles algunos ejemplos.
Como psicóloga finalmente
me voy a dedicar a las personas
y estos ejemplos son
precisamente de estas personas.
Les presento a Édgar,
Édgar fue estudiante de esta institución,
estudió licenciatura en Comunicación.
Cuando le pregunté a Édgar,
cómo podría definir su transformación
desde que era estudiante hasta la fecha,
me atreví precisamente
a poner sus palabras textuales
para no cambiar el significado
de sus palabras
y de su sentimiento, él me dijo:
“Es el descubrimiento del arte
y la poesía en todas sus formas”
y verdaderamente me sorprendió
que Édgar
que lo conocí como estudiante,
con todas sus dudas e inquietudes
que todos los que hemos sido estudiantes
aquí hemos tenido alguna vez,
me pudiera hablar sobre estos términos
tan exquisitos y elevados
sobre todo refiriéndose
a la estética y al arte.
Al parecer, Édgar en una sala de cine
puede aprender mucho
y puede transformase mucho,
y él me decía precisamente
en esta anécdota
que una vez salió de una sala de cine
de ver una película
de un cineasta muy renombrado y dijo:
“Salí en ese momento de la sala
y pude sentir por unos minutos
que el mundo es un tiempo
de gran belleza”.
Gran sorpresa para mí,
muy grata sorpresa que Édgar
esté en esta transformación
con estas características.
Finalmente, Édgar vive hoy
en Bruselas, Bélgica
es director de comunicación
de la empresa SIGNIS,
que es una asociación
católica mundial para comunicación.
Édgar se ha transformado.
También les presento a Estela,
Estela fue mi alumna, fue alumna también
de esta universidad,
fue alumna becaria,
y cuando también hablé con ella
sobre su transformación,
yo acuerdo con Estela
sobre su descripción.
Estela era más bien una chica reservada,
muy estudiosa,
yo podría decir que hasta introvertida,
pero esto ya no tiene nada que ver
con sus características de hoy día
Y cuando le pregunté a Estela
sobre su transformación
desde aquella época hasta la fecha,
precisamente me dijo:
“Conectar con lo que somos
en todas las dimensiones de nuestra vida,
no solo intelectualmente,
sino también desde el alma”.
Estela actualmente
trabaja como directora general
de la Fundación Don Bosco
en Cuernavaca
y cuando me describía precisamente
los momentos en los que se sintió
tocada y transformada, me dice:
“Yo como estudié la licenciatura
como becaria,
tuve que hacer mi servicio becario
en un área en donde nadie quería hacerlo,
que era el servicio de la fotocopiadora”,
dice: “Paradójicamente,
cuando estaba yo en ese servicio
entré en contacto con otras áreas
de la universidad que desconocía
y me di cuenta qué hacían
esas áreas de la universidad”
“Y no me cabe la menor duda
que en ese servicio becario
encontré la vocación
de lo que actualmente hago”.
Lo que les dije del puesto de Estela
es su parte oficial,
extraoficialmente y la última vez
que me crucé con ella,
fue precisamente en los foros
de paz y reconciliación
que se hicieron a lo largo del país,
me la encontré aquí en Acapulco,
nos invitó a colaborar
a varias personas de la Loyola.
Cuando digo que
las características que tenía Estela
de estudiante ya no se parecen,
es porque efectivamente
ahora veo a Estela librando
codo con codo diálogos,
conversaciones y negociaciones
con políticos, académicos e intelectuales
que promueven precisamente
la paz y la reconciliación en México.
También no me cabe duda que Estela
se ha transformado considerablemente.
Pero estos ejemplos que les doy
finalmente son ejemplos positivos.
Podemos también tener ejemplos negativos.
Tenemos ejemplos de sicarios por ejemplo,
que terminan con la vida
más que procurarla, o preservarla o lo
que nos genere esta parte de la evolución,
pues tenemos estas personas
que más bien acaban con ella,
podríamos decir entonces
que estas personas más bien
son como mutantes
que terminan con la vida ¿no?
Entonces, nosotros, seres humanos
siempre estamos en transformación,
a veces, aunque no lo sepamos,
es claro que vamos a cambiar de estatura,
de talla, de físico,
pero también vamos a cambiar
de personalidad, y muchas veces
ustedes pueden haber visto a una persona
que conocieron hace mucho tiempo,
dejaron de verla, y precisamente
se cuestionan muchas veces
acerca de “qué pasó con esta persona
que yo conocí, era así y así y así
y ahora resulta que nada de lo que
yo conocí existe actualmente o no lo veo”.
Entonces también trabajamos
en el cambio de la persona,
de la personalidad y los rasgos
que nos acontecen.
Y estos cambios
muchas veces perversos que tenemos
se ven ejemplificados
de una manera muy adecuada
con el libro "Dorian Grey" de Oscar Wilde.
Y precisamente para ustedes
que ya lo conocen,
les recuerdo que el señor Dorian Grey
tenía un pacto con el mal,
y debido a ese pacto solamente
sus vilezas y sus canalladas
se veían reflejadas en el retrato,
pero él podía permanecer joven y bello.
¿Cuál es la metáfora que nos dice Wilde
sobre estos asuntos?
Bueno, la metáfora es que
precisamente el señor Grey
vivía una vida bastante trivial y vacía.
Es decir, podía sobrevivir
durante tiempo y tiempo,
todos sus amigos se habían ido
porque ya habían muerto,
pero él seguía siendo joven y bello.
Se caracterizaba por
andar de fiesta en fiesta,
de parranda en parranda,
de amores frustrados,
de engaños constantes,
inclusive de asesinatos,
y finalmente el señor Grey
cuando va al sótano y ve su retrato,
termina con su miserable vida,
destruyendo el retrato,
y destruyéndose también a sí mismo.
¿Qué es lo que sucedió con el señor Grey?
Bueno, pues el señor Grey
puso la fórmula de "primero yo,
después yo y al último yo,
que es finalmente la fórmula perfecta para
vivir una vida egoísta y sin trascendencia
Y llego finalmente
al punto central de mi plática
que es la trascendencia,
porque cuando trascendemos
también tendemos a auto realizarnos,
y cuando trascendemos,
pasamos precisamente de ser
la parte egoísta del señor Grey
a la parte más bien colectiva
que nos permite aprehender al universo
y poder preocuparnos
por el resto de las personas
y del resto de los problemas
que en algún momento dado
podemos ser útiles
o podemos trabajar sobre ellos.
“Moverse más allá
de las preocupaciones individuales
hacia temas o problemas
más colectivos o universales”.
Es lo que les decía, entonces dejamos
de ser ese egocentrismo,
dejamos de trabajar en ese narcisismo
y podemos percibir al mundo
precisamente como un colectivo
en donde nos podemos insertar,
en donde podemos trabajar y servir.
Y eso también se representa
en la autorrealización.
Les voy a poner algunos ejemplos
del programa del señor Anderson Cooper.
Hay un proyecto que se llama Héroes
que probablemente alguno de ustedes
lo han escuchado.
Estos son personas que estuvieron
postuladas para recibir ese premio
en 2018, precisamente
por su trabajo social.
Ella es María, y trabaja
en un sistema de software
para poder eficientar el desabastecimiento
de alimentos en albergues
que recupera de los restaurantes
o de los supermercados.
Entonces María trabaja en eso.
Florence trabaja también en dar
clases gratis a ciudadanos inmigrantes
que están en Estados Unidos tanto de
inglés como de ciudadanía norteamericana,
y Florence para mí es muy especial
porque como ustedes ven,
no es una adolescente
o una joven como María,
y sin embargo está trabajando
para mejorar la colectividad.
Y tenemos también a Ricardo,
que en Latinoamérica genera albergues para
niños que están enfermos y sus familias,
y que les da precisamente habitación
mientras dan la terapia en el hospital,
y tienen que quedarse en la ciudad.
Entonces estas personas finalmente
se las pongo como ejemplo
de transformación y de trascendencia,
de autorregulación.
En palabras probablemente
del presidente John F. Keneddy,
sería traducirlo a algo como:
"No necesitas preguntar
qué puede hacer tu país por ti,
sino que puedes hacer tú por tu país".
Este sentido de colectividad y de ayuda,
que ayuda a trascender a la persona.
Lo que les quiero decir entonces,
es que para poder transformar,
primero tenemos que trascender,
y para trascender tenemos
que trabajar con nosotros mismos,
es decir, el trabajo
primero es íntimo y personal
y después podemos salir hacia
nuestra comunidad para poder transformar.
Es claro que Edgar trasciende
cada vez que ve una película
y transforma cuando nos puede explicar
la belleza y la poesía
de una narración cinematográfica.
Es claro que Estela trasciende
cuando ayuda a sus semejantes
a vivir en un mundo mejor
y definitivamente impacta y transforma
su contexto cuando intenta sanar a las
víctimas de la violencia en este país.
No se diga María, Florence y Ricardo
que con su dedicación y su esfuerzo
pueden impactar el contexto.
Yo los invito precisamente
a que hagamos ese viaje interno
para poder salir renovados.
Los invito finalmente
a convertirnos en bellas mariposas
y embellecer el mundo.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)